[Music]
as a business with a presence in the
cloud you might need to allow a third
party to use login credentials from a
different identity provider than what
you currently use let's follow the
example of omni retail to see how that
might look and how you would handle it
Omni retail provides services to their
customers with the rich set of solutions
that Google offers
they bring together data from multiple
sources across their sales Finance
inventory supplier and CRM systems into
bigquery for seamless analysis
sales staff then use a custom sales web
application to directly access those
reports and insights derived from
bigquery to provide better customer
experiences
bailstaff already use Workforce identity
Federation with their identity provider
to authenticate to bigquery Via a jdbc
connector
Omni retail faces the issue that it is
not able to share these same insights
with the international sales staff at
their affiliate run stores
those stores were outsourced to a
separate company called omnisales
worldwide who used their own totally
separate identity provider for
Authentication
due to regulatory policies in certain
locations the omnisales worldwide user
accounts could not use the identity
provider already in use
how did Omni retail share their sales
data with their affiliate run stores
Omni retail created a new Workforce pool
for omnisales worldwide to authenticate
and authorize omnisales worldwide sales
staff
now all of the sales teams can access
the bigquery data through the same
Custom Sales web application but
leverage their own identity provider for
authentication while still using single
sign-on
Workforce identity Federation supports
sinkless attribute-based single sign-on
so all user management of the
international staff can continue to be
maintained by omnisales worldwide
Omni retail was able to authorize access
to the correct users by using attributes
associated with user logins and by
creating a separate Workforce pool for
the new identity Provider by delivering
more insights to more users Omni retail
empowers the sales teams to increase the
sales per customer because all access is
authenticated and an access management
process enforced Omni retail has
confidence their data is still protected
if you'd like to learn more about how
Workforce identity Federation can help
you maintain security and gain
flexibility as to who can log in click
the link in the description or search
for Workforce identity Federation at
cloud.google.com
[Music]